MEMO WITH ALARM AND WILD
ACCUSATIONS ON MSNBC RATHER
THAN DISCUSS THE CONTENT OF
THE MEMO, THEY WERE SO
CONCERNED ABOUT AUTHORSHIP
AND PROTECTING DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD
ROSENSTEIN.
>> WHAT ROLE DID THE WHITE
HOUSE, IN FACT, PLAY IN THE
PRODUCTION OF THIS MEMO?
WE KNOW HOW IT PLAYED OUT
SEVERAL MONTHS AGO WHEN
DEVIN NUNES MADE THAT
MIDNIGHT RUN HERE TO THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> THE JOE MCCARTHY IS TO DO
IT I HAVE IN MY HANDS A
DOCUMENT.
IT'S SOMETHING THEY PUT --
AND WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO
IT COULD WELL HAVE BEEN
WRITTEN BY WHITE HOUSE STAFF
PEOPLE.
>> Laura: LET'S GET A
RESPONSE TO THAT WILD
CONJECTURE AND THEY SAY
TRUMP MAKES STUFF UP.
YOU GOT TO BE KIDDING.
THIS HOGAN GIDLEY HERE TO
DISCUSS THE PRESIDENT'S NEXT
MOVE.
OKAY, YOU HEARD IT YOU HEARD
THAT.
WE RULED YOU OUT.
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> Laura: THIS IS ONE OF THE
LINES OF ATTACK TODAY THAT
THERE WAS A COORDINATED
COME UP WITH THE IDEA FOR
THE MEMO AND THEN TO PUSH
FOR THE RELEASE OF THE MEMO
THREE THINGS COME UP WITH
THE IDEA FOR THE MEMO, DRAFT
WHAT CAN YOU SAY TO US
TONIGHT DID THE WHITE HOUSE
COORDINATE ON ANY OF THOSE
THREE LEVELS.
>> WE DIDN'T COME UP WITH
IT, WE DIDN'T DRAFT IT, WE
DIDN'T RELEASE IT THAT'S
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY
RIDICULOUS.
SEEMS LIKE A DIVERSIFICATION DIV
SEEMS LIKE A DIVERSIFICATION DIR
SEEMS LIKE A DIVERSIFICATION DII
SEEMS LIKE A DIVERSIFICATION DIN
SEEMS LIKE A DIVERSIFICATION DIO
SEEMS LIKE A DIVERSIFICATION DIF
HIGHEST LEVELS AT BOTH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
FBI.
AND, LAURA, WHEN CAN TAKE
AND USE THE MOST INVASIVE
SURVEILLANCE TECHNIQUES ON
AMERICAN CITIZENS, THAT
SHOULD BE SERIOUS CONCERN TO
MOST PEOPLE.
>> Laura: WHERE WHERE ARE
ALL THE CIVIL LIBERTARIANS
DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
THEY USED TO CARE ABOUT
UNLAWFUL SEARCH AND SEIZURE
WHICH, I GUESS, CARTER PAGE
ACCORDING TO THE STATUTE.
THE DEMOCRATS, APPARENTLY
THAT'S JUST OUT THE WIND
DOUGH.
>> THE DOSSIER THEY WANTED
IT WAS OUT.
THEY WANTED ALL THAT STUFF
OUT.
FOR SOME REASON THEY DIDN'T
WANT THIS MEMO OUT.
I FIND THAT VERY CURIOUS.
IT'S A DOUBLE STANDARD.
WHEN IT SUITS THEIR
PLEASURE, THEY WANT TO KEEP
IT QUIET.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
OBVIOUSLY IS OF DEEP CONCERN
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO
USE A DEMOCRAT FUNDED
DOCUMENT THAT'S CLEARLY USED
FOR, YOU KNOW, IT'S A
CAMPAIGN OPO DUMP TO USE
DOING WHEN THEY ARE SIGNING
FISA WARRANTS, THAT'S VERY
DANGEROUS.
>> Laura: THERE WAS ANOTHER
LINE OF ATTACK TODAY BY THE
DEMOCRATS I WOULD LIKE YOU
TO RESPOND TO.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I'M NOT SURPRISED THAT
DECLASSIFYING THIS
INFORMATION ENDANGERS
NATIONAL SECURITY.
THE SO-CALLED NUNES MEMO,
THREATENS EXTREMELY
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION AND
ENDANGERS SOURCES AND
METHODS OF OUR INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY.
>> TO BE FRIVOLOUS WITH
THEIR IDENTITY OR ROADS THAT
NANCY ON A FRIDAY NIGHT.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION HERE?
YOU ARE ENDANGERING NATIONAL
SECURITY.
NO CLASSIFIED INFORMATION OR
SOURCES OR METHODS IN THIS
MEMO AT ALL.
WE DIDN'T REDACT A WORD.
IT CAME OUT TODAY, THE FBI
WORKED WITH NUNES TO TRY TO
DECLASSIFY SOME OF THESE
SAME SOURCES AND METHODS.
AND THAT'S FINE.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
BUT, I MEAN, IT'S ABSOLUTELY
RIDICULOUS TO SAY ON THE ONE
HAND THIS IS GOING TO
THREATEN NATIONAL SECURITY
LIVES ARE GOING TO BE AT
RISK.
THEN WHEN IT COMES OUT THEY
SAY THAT'S A NOTHING BURGER.
WHICH IS IT?
THEY KNEW IT AHEAD OF TIME.
>> Laura: PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO DIE AND HOGAN GIDLEY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HAVE YOU
BLOOD ON YOUR HANDS.
THIS IS WHERE THEY ARE
GOING.
>> RIGHT.
THEY DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH OPEN BORDERS BY THE
WAY.
>> Laura: NO, NO.
BY THE WAY THE DAILY BEAST,
JUST FOR FUN.
THE DAILY BEAST HAS A
HEADLINE OUT TONIGHT.
THROW THIS UP ON THE SCREEN.
TRUMP'S WHITE HOUSE GOES
WEIRDLY SILENT ON THE NUNES
MEMO.
WAIT A SECOND.
YOU ARE HERE WITH US AND I
THINK MERCEDES HAS BEEN OUT
THERE.
TALKING ABOUT?
WEIRDLY SILENT.
THAT'S CRAZY.
BY THE WAY, JOHN MCCAIN HAS
TWEETED OUT A REACTION TO
THIS.
IS HE NOT HAPPY AT ALL.
WHAT CAN WE PUT THAT UP ON
SCREEN THE EMERGENCY
SCREEN THE MMERGENCY
SCREEN THE MCCRGENCY
SCREEN THE MCCAIENCY
SCREEN THE MCCAIN?CY
LATEST ATTACKS ON THE FBI
AND DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
SERVE NO AMERICAN INTEREST.
NO PARTIES.
NO PRESIDENTS, ONLY PUTIN'S
HOGAN.
>> HOW IN THE WORLD CAN YOU
SEE THE TEXT MESSAGES THAT
HAVE COME OUT FROM PEOPLE AT
THE HIGHEST LEVELS.
NOT THE PEOPLE WE RESPECT.
APPRECIATE THEIR HARD WORK.
THE TOP LINE FOLKS WHO WERE
IN THE HILLARY CLINTON
INVESTIGATION WITH AN
OBVIOUS PRO-HILLARY CLINTON
BIAS AND ANTI-DONALD TRUMP
BIAS AND NOT BE CONCERNED
WHATSOEVER WITH THAT?
>> Laura: IS THE PRESIDENT
GOING TO FIRE ROSENSTEIN?
IF HE FIRES ROSENSTEIN IT
WILL BE A POLITICAL
FIRESTORM.
I THINK IT'S BETTER TO HAVE
HIM TO STAY IN MY VIEW.
>> NO CONSIDERATION FOR
FIRING ROD ROSENSTEIN.
HE APPROVED ONE OF THE FISA
WARRANTS.
OAK.
MY VIEW FIRING HIM IS THE
LEFT IS BEGGING FOR IT.
THEY BEGGED FOR MUELLER AND
NOW ROSENSTEIN.
THEY HAVE A NEW TARGET.
>> WEIRDLY SIGH LENGTHS
THING.
WE WERE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION.
THEY SAID IF YOU FIRE
ROSENSTEIN, IT'S A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS.
WE CAME OUT AND SAID WE ARE
NOT FIRING HIM.
THEY GO.
>> Laura: WHITE HOUSE.
>> WEIRDLY SILENT.
>> Laura: IF I EVER -- I'M
JUST GOING TO CALL YOU
WEIRDLY SILENT.